HOBLINKE SMUFOR JOINING US.
ISTEN T DEWAAN SIX
WEEKS O.>> YOUENITENELAPSE.
HA T
REACHT
COSION.
TH TO BE NCIRCUMSTANCE WHERE YOF
AN OD THERE IS GOING TO
O
COUNTRY IS HIGHLY UNLIKELY.
KABUL.RERYS YOU KNOWLI IN ON
WERE VACHE EMBASSYG NTS, BIDEN
TR T  TRE
IND PRESIDENT BIDEN GET THISSO ?
>> JAKE, FIRSTETS CONT DISCURE N
LKS WHED US ON 11.AT IS
ARS WE B JUS.
V T ANISTATESPOT T CAPABLE OF
CONDUCTITTACSTAN.
TOEEP IN PLACE IY TO SEE
AN-EMERGTHON E TERMS WE W
AF
WE'VCCIENGOBJECTIVES.
MAKE.E HE HAD DECISI
NET WITH THED THAT O
FORCES, ONLY A
KECOUNTRY ON MAYT THE COULD HMAB
SIMPLY WRONG.
D THE PRESIDENT
DECIDED TO KEEAFGHANISTAstCKS W
ATTACKING OUR FORC O PERIO T
HED TO
THE OFFENSIVE YOU ARE SEEING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO TAKE
HA
COMMCE H WAR D PROBABLY BE ON
SIMPLY. TODAPLNGENANRICAN FORCEL
THAT'S T C WE'RE DEALI
WITH.>> YOU THE 1st NEGOTIATE TP
ON THROUGH THA
WE DID HAVTROOPS THEREER1st.
AGAI TE IS N
JUST THE WITHDL OF U.SRC TY WER.
AMCALLEDT OBAM
THE WAY THIS WAS, E TALIBAN AN
THEMO
OUT AFGHANEOPLE.
CROCKER CONTINUED,, I'M
LEFT WITH SOMEVEY MIND ABILITY
TO LEAD OUR NATION AS
COMMAN.
HSOOR UNDERSTOOD
LIKELTO HAPPEN AN
NODOES PRESIDENT BID N BEA
R TH
ATT ANY  SINCE00WHEN IT WAS LAS
THTHTHAT WE
TED.
AN WW THEY WERE VERY  CLEG E AN
INVESTED OVE MI
DOLLARS ALONG WITH T
BUILDING A MODERMI
DIDN'T HAVE.FA IWE'VS BEEN UNAB
THE COUNTRY. HAPPEMO QAN WANTIPE
G ABLE TO DEFEND, I
AN OF EXPERTS
BELIEVE AND YOU CAN DISAGREE IF
YOS AT
SUPPORT, H INTELLENRE T THE
AFGHAN TROD IS
WHATFFEIR SPIND
WHAT TH DO.AT IS E R ULD
VE ST   FORCE.
AND NOW ISDIP  5,000 MEMBERS BA
THAT N OE
EXIT WASLY PLANNED
AGAIN, LOOK.
YOU TOLD MNT
T YOGHT IT
WAS ENLYY THE
IN
COUNTRY.
BUT PRESIDENT BIDEN MONTH, QUOTI
HE WASROT WEESENISBL A
ANYTHING HAPPENING OE .
SAID ADDITION --ENT ADDITIONAL
FORCES IN, WHAT TH
OVED IN A NE
ALSOE  EVERYTHING EEDEESIN PLACE
G OUT OF
AFGHAN
K.
ATEXAC
DO AVE THE TROOPS IN
>> AGACKE FORE TG UT
ITH
USINABLE.
OTTHS AN
RED
COME OUT ON MAY D WE NOT BEGUN N
THE TALI
WBE W
WITH TENS OF THOUSANDSNG TO GO O
ESPECIAL A THEHOOWE AFGHAN CES.E
WO NOTHINGY ORO SEE US
IN A ANOTHER FIVE,
IS SIMPLYOTE ON
INTEREST.>>CHANGIJETO WHETH WE .
TAKING OUT ALL THE ONE
MEMBERBE THOSE AMERI
ANE AF TRANSLATO
THEN YOU HE D PEOPCK IN.
ATFINITION OOHOU
TROOPS OUT BEC NEN I
PREPARED F
EV
FORWARD.
WE HHES OND.D THEY
VERY QUICKLY AGAINE
OFFERING THE TALIBAN ANYINEXCHA
PASSANHANISTAN
IBAN F
AN
THEY INTERFEONNEL, WITH
CEINS
DR BE A SWT D DECISIVE RESPONSE.
YOU OM A DO YOU THIN WILIT T
AND SO WE HAVE AE EMBASS HAVE SA
AFY ARMOEFIN
PLACE THE MEANS TOO THAT.AND BEL
NT
ALSO,NOT QUIFE SO-CALL S THE F
POSSIBLY CAN FOR
CAN, TO EM O IS
WHAT TWA
EVACUATE THESE THOUS O WE'VE BEO
AFGHAN TRANSLATORS AND OTHERS
. SERVICE MEMBERS
DURINGHE.
STN
AMBASSADOR, JUST A DO,INTERAGEN.
THOUSANDS OF THESE FOLKS ARE NOW
PE.
RYT TO
IT IS NOT SAFE.
I KNOW TWOIEUTENANTS, OFUNDMTO V
?HEIATORS.D ESO O
>> IN FACT TK FORC
BEEN GOING FOR M WEEKS
NOW AND AMSSACOBSEN EECE FORNY .
AND WE HAVE BEEN WORKING THIS O
AS YOUE REFUGESS AND SUPPO
NG TD .
AT
CAN TO PEOPLE OUT OF HARM'T IS O
.>> PEOI ACTIV VERARD FROM THE
ST PEOPLE. ESY OOPLE FOR A.
DOUBLIOW S OF OUR ABILYONE WHOHO
TO GET>>O TO MAKE SURE HAV PV
RECOGN
NMENT.
WOULD THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ERNMENT AT UPHOL RHTHAESN'ER ME.
CONVERSELYMET ESN'T
ASS OF WIGNSOR ALLIED NEGOING  ,
TANCE OM
UPPORT FROM E IO
THWON'T
BASIC E AFGHAN EVER
G HOUS.
A
YOU WOULVER GN
D ON WHAE TALIBAN TH D
E OGIRLS.
AFGHANISTAN RIGHT YOUN
SEXUAL.AK
A MO KAB TRIR OF THEM JUSTO ADEG
S  TERNATIONAL INS TO  EVERYTHIR
SUSTAIN R GHAND AT THE AI SAID
TOT IF TESIFN
CHARGE, THAT IS
THE IEFO
THOSE RIGHTS.
WE WIL CAN
MAKE SURE CASE.
>> EVERYTHIN T
AVOIDING AAIGOA DEN IS INTENT ON
E  HASTY
TNAMG U.S.
>> NO WE'RMENOT SAIGON'T WE ALRE
WE WENT TO 20 YE ONE MISSIONAND
WEEET
MISSION.
THING O ATTACKED UING SURE
'T ATTRO
AFGHANISTAN, WE'VEED MSIED
ME, REMAINING IN R ANOTHER ONE,
LONG TIME IN THEh NT THERE FOR
'V TWICE A
T
AS NATIOT E.
THINK MOST OF OUC
COMPOR D  R US TREMAIN ITAN , F
TEN YEARD
D TO BEING A
>> YOU DON'T THINKT NOW ISNG
HOTBED  TERRI WY RE CAPACITY T
TERTERRORISM.
IN PLACES  WORLD WHERE HAVE FOR
, PARTS OFOF, WE ALE TO Y POTENA
TERRORIST THREAT TO OUR COUNTRAN
REGION THEE HORIZOALL IT TSE
AND  WRE-EMERGENCE ST
TALIBAN IS GDO
T ORA RRORIST GROUGETHN  ST HAPE